we are joined Now by commissioner
Brendan Carr of the FCC that's the
federal agency that oversees our
country's communication laws and
regulations commissioner Carr good
morning I want to clarify you don't have
direct control or regulatory power over
Tick Tock now that could change but you
have been leading and shaping opinion on
this issue so to the more than 100
million Americans who are using this
apparently without great concern why do
you support a ban yeah look I think the
evidence we have now is is crystal clear
for years Tick Tock represented that
very little data if any goes back to
Beijing and there was a blockbuster
story over the summer that got internal
Communications that said No in fact
quote everything is seen in China there
was a story that they were using the app
Tick Tock to surreptitiously surveil the
locations of specific Americans they
denied it later internal emails came out
that said no we're doing it as the
segment noted FBI and doj are looking at
that the head of our most recent midterm
elections the CCP State media set up
Tick Tock accounts to Target politicians
here for divisive content so I think we
have a lot of evidence of the risk and
look I testified before that same
committee many times sat in that same
chair and I've never seen anything like
that really the day could not have gone
any worse for tick tock
do you think we'd be having this kind of
conversation if Tick Tock were owned by
say a Swedish company or a Finnish
company like Angry Birds or Spotify for
example is it about it being Chinese
it's really driving all this concern
you know look we have a baseline level
of concern with all applications whether
they're based in Europe or Silicon
Valley itself we've had a lot of
hearings in Congress about that and
there's work right now on sort of data
privacy laws they'll put some baseline
Protections in place for everybody but
what we're seeing is for something
exceptionally unique about Tick Tock and
one way we can see that is there's a
sister abdoyon that's available in China
Tick Tock itself is not and there they
show education material Museum exhibits
science experiments to kids and here we
get things like content that shows young
girls eating disorder and self-harm and
so I think there's something very unique
about it that's why you see bipartisan
support FBI director Chris Ray Democrat
Senator Mark Warner Sheriff Senate Intel
saying that Tick Tock itself scares the
Dickens out of him yeah their their
parental concerns or security concerns
lawmakers seem to have a pretty clear
line of thought on this you know Tick
Tock is owned by bite dance bite dances
Chinese and are there Chinese law it is
accountable to the Communist party there
in that country with that chain of
events is there anything short of an
outright ban that you would support
now I don't see it at this point maybe
in the white house last week reports
where they went to tick tock and said
look you either have to divest Chinese
government ownership Chinese ownership
or face a potential ban I think that's
the right thing that the most important
thing that The Tick Tock CEO had to do
yesterday was built some level of trust
and credibility with Congress and in
that effort I think he completely failed
and so we'll see look there's still a
lot of time left there's still a lot of
issues potential hurdles to get
legislation passed or get the treasury
Department which is looking at this to
take action but really the trust is just
bottoming out for tick tock uh it
doesn't look good look there's 150
million Americans that are on this for
sure and so we got to make the case to
them very clearly that there's a risk
here
all right commissioner uh well you made
that case this morning thank you very
much thanks